as of 2022 this year
what's your final analysis of the
political leadership in the human
mind and the human being of
donald trump
i sort of avoided this for years
just talking about trump i tried to
avoid talking about trump for years same
reason i tried to avoid writing about
brexit do you think that trump just
sorry on a small tangent do you think
the trump story
is uh over are we just done with volume
one i've no idea the people i know who
know him said he's running
um
and uh
and i think that in in general
republicans have to
do have a choice in front of them
and one friend put it to me recently
said
you've got to go in with your toughest
fighter
and
i understand that
instinct and i also think it's very
dangerous instinct because what is your
toughest fight is also your biggest
liability
um what's the best way to get out the
democrat vote than 2024 than to have
donald trump running and the people that
are doing the war in the west are pretty
tough
fighters
they are
and um
i'm cautious about this because i know
every way i tread it's dangerous but let
me just
just be treated gracefully i'll try it
as gracefully as i can
my wellington boots
i am i galoshes
i here's here's the thing
uh i think everybody knows what trump is
i think we all knew for years
and i feel sorry for the conservatives
who had to pretend that he was
something he wasn't i felt sorry for the
ones who had to
pretend that for instance he was a some
devout christian or
a man of faith or a man of great
integrity or
uh all of these sorts of things because
i'm not in the public eye for years it'd
been obvious that wasn't the case
but but
he has something extraordinary
one thing is a method of me
communication that you've just got to
say is was unbelievable
you know in one fundamental way that you
can't look away for some reason look
away i mean we
i
i've been watching him clear everyone
out of the way in 2016. it was thrilling
because those people needed clearing
away
you know sam is just horrified what
america is going to give us another bush
what's so great about this family
um
america is going to give us another
clinton we're going to get to choose any
clinton on the bush
mark stein said whatever we'll just wait
for the day the clintons and the bushes
in to marry and then we can really have
a monarchy again um
so
i i i was very pleased to see him clear
them away i was very clear to you please
see him
sort of
raise some of the issues that needed
raising i thought it was a sort of
breath of fresh air and i wished it
wasn't him doing it
um
and then there was a question of him
governing and it was just perfectly
clear he didn't know how to govern
he what he did have however what he does
have is an incredible ability to fight
and some of the forces he was arraigned
against were arraigned against him my
gosh they would have taken down anyone
else
i mean
if they'd have probably done some
similar bs against ted cruz if he you
know or marco rubio you know they'd have
said there's some some people admitted
they'd they'd have accused all these
people of racism and misogyny and
everything else as well just so they'd
admit romney just like they did john
mccain
um but
trump was the one ugly enough and bruisy
enough to fight
and also a willingness
or a lack of willingness
to play sort of
the civil
yes game of politics sort of you know at
a party
when um
like politeness gets you in trouble yeah
i mean show up and everybody's polite
and you just out of momentum want to be
being polite and all of a sudden you're
on an island with jeffrey epstein and uh
it gets you into a huge amount of
trouble but so so trump has these sort
of extraordinary qualities but i just
you know look he he he screwed up uh
during his time in office because he
didn't achieve as much as he should have
done now you could say about every
president but i refuse to acknowledge
that two years when he had both houses
in the first the beginning he just
didn't know what levers to pull
you know i mean he was sitting in the
office behind the oval office tweeting
watching the news
i'm sorry that's not a president
and um
he couldn't fill and didn't fill
positions because people knew i mean
people who were very loyal to him
he would just
you know he'd get them to do something
loyal and then destroy them
and i i think and then we get onto the
thing about i'm here we get on to the
you know what of course is very very
fractious terrain but
you know i covered the 2020 election and
i was traveling all around the states
and i went to trump rally and
and all sorts of stuff and
i i mean i was in dc on election night
and
um when and it got very ugly at one
point um in so-called black lives matter
plaza
when it looked like trump might win when
florida came in and got really i could
feel the air well very very heated and
like some antifa people started getting
into black lock and this sort of stuff
and i thought this town's going to burn
you know if trump wins
and
in the aftermath of the vote
i was waiting to hang around and
watching for a bit and then i thought it
was going to drag on
and i saw some of his people and others
and people told me they had great
evidence of vote rigging and all this
sort of thing
and i'm afraid i'm one of those people
who doesn't believe that the evidence
that they've presented is good enough to
justify the claim that he won the
election
and
i and people say have you seen 2 000
mules and have you seen
look
the evidence isn't there that the the
election was won by donald trump yeah
and i think that what he did on january
the sixth was
unbelievably dangerous
and you know here it is possible for us
to hold two ideas in our head at the
same time january 6 was not nothing
nor was it an insurrection an attempt to
stage a coup
and
there's a vanishing number of people in
the u.s was eric weinstein said that the
it's like
this is the
the roof
that you have to walk along and like the
the sides are very steep
yeah if you fall off either side
you